Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Der italienische Fußball hat nicht nur die Champions League und Europa League Wochen bestimmt, sondern ja auch noch einen Liga-Betrieb. Über all das wollen wir sprechen mit Christian Bernhard, den ihr natürlich schon kennt aus dem letzten Kurzpass.
Hallo Max, grüß dich.
Sehr schön, dass wir mal wieder miteinander sprechen. Das ist so ein bisschen so eine Emergency-Folge hier. Eigentlich hätte ich Serie A vielleicht erst nächste Woche oder übernächste Woche gemacht. Aber da gab es ja so ein paar Champions-League-Spiele mit italienischer Beteiligung, die nicht so schlecht waren.
Ja, ich glaube, die letzten Europapokal-Dage gab es schon mal langweiligere. Kann man vielleicht es so zusammenfassen.
Absolut und endlich mal nicht dieselben Nasen im Halbfinale. Das ist echt angenehm. Also mit einigen Ausnahmen, über die Ausnahmen müssen wir auch noch sprechen, zumindest zum Teil. Aber ich würde ja vorschlagen, lasst uns mit der magischen Nacht von Rom beginnen, mit dem 3 zu 0 der Roma gegen Barca. Was ist da passiert?
Was ist da passiert? Das fragen sich auch in Rom einige, wobei man vielleicht auch gleich sagen muss. Also mit dem Wunder, sage ich jetzt mal, haben die jetzt logischerweise nicht kalkuliert. Das wäre sehr vermessen. Aber man hat schon auch nach dem Hinspiel gemerkt, dass sie das so eingeschätzt haben, dass das 4 zu 1 viel zu hoch war, dass da auch sehr viel Pech dabei war, was ja auch die einzelne Szene, zwei Eigentore und so weiter gezeigt haben. Und man hat wirklich gemerkt, dass die Francesca auch und so das Umfeld gesagt hat, okay, das Ding ist noch nicht komplett durch. Wir brauchen logischerweise weiß Gott was alles. Und das ist ja klar, dass man das gegen Barca braucht. Aber man hat wirklich an der Einstellung schon gemerkt, dass die das Ding noch nicht abgeschrieben hatten. Und das, finde ich, hat man dann von der ersten Minute an gesehen, in Rom, im Spiel.
Und hat dich die Art und Weise überrascht, oder hätte man das wissen können, wenn man Roma ein bisschen enger verfolgt hätte? Also ich spreche jetzt ein bisschen aus meiner Brille.
Also wie dominant sie das über 90 Minuten geschafft haben, hat mich logischerweise überrascht. Also die Roma muss man ja vielleicht auch als Vorgeschichte wissen. Es haben vielleicht einige schon vergessen. Es ist ja nicht so, dass die Roma jetzt plötzlich so von heute auf morgen in der Champions League so was, also so was beeindruckendes abgeliefert hat. Wenn man nur ein paar Monate zurückdenkt, die sind in einer Gruppe mit Chelsea und Atletico als Erster weitergekommen. Das ist ja schon mal nicht das Schlechteste. Die schlechteste Visitenkarte. Plus haben sie kein einziges Tor zuhause bekommen in der ganzen Champions League, was man auch einfach mal stehen lassen kann. So viel dazu nur einmal zum Rahmen. Wie gesagt, die Intensität, wie sie Barca einfach fast 90 Minuten nicht haben Barca sein lassen, das war wirklich beeindruckend. Das war dann im Prinzip auch das, glaube ich, was es dann ausgemacht hat. Also klar kamen alles zusammen. Sie hatten das frühe Tor, das sie gebraucht haben. Solche Momente braucht man logischerweise. Aber ich habe in Erinnerung, ich glaube, das war um die 75. oder 77. Minute rum, da waren das erste Mal so zwei Minuten, dass man das Barca gesehen hat, dass man eigentlich kennt. Also, dass sie den Ball vor dem 16. hin und her laufen haben lassen, die Roma mal ein bisschen hinten eingeschnürt. Das gab es bis zur 75. nicht einmal. Also wirklich nicht eine Phase, wo sie mal über einen längeren Zeitraum ihr Spiel aufgezogen haben. Und das lag logischerweise sehr viel an der Art und Weise, wie die Roma, wie sie sich aggressiv angelaufen sind und wie sie ihnen einfach wirklich die Lust am Spielen, aber halt auch den Platz und das Ding am Spielen genommen haben.
Ja, da hatte ich auch so einen kurzen Moment. Oh, jetzt könnte vielleicht der Tank langsam leer werden.
Klar.
So ein bisschen wie in der Formel 1, wenn sie auf einmal ausruhen lassen müssen. Ach ja, die Formel 1 ist ein anderes lustiges Thema. Aber dann kam ja noch das 3 zu 0. Und lassen uns nochmal auf diese Roma-Mannschaft gucken. Denn das letzte Mal haben wir länger über so Mannschaften wie Turin und Neapel gesprochen, was da für Leute einfach spielen. Und in der Mitte, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, thront über allem Rossi.
Ja, ich finde, das ist auch die Geschichte. Also man kann logisch, dass Tseko herausragend nicht nur gegen Barca gespielt hat. Ich weiß nicht, ob der einen Ball aus der Luft nicht festgemacht hat oder nicht gehalten hat. Auf jeden Fall waren es nicht viele. Das Manolas dann eben, der schon seit zwei Jahren richtig, richtig stark spielt und auch schon bei sehr vielen auf dem Zettel ist, das ist alles, das stimmt alles und das sind logisch viele. Aber ich finde, der Rossi ist halt einfach der, der diese Mentalität und auch diese Romanitare, also dieses Römische, halt einfach verkörpert, wie kann man andere. Und das ist logisch eine sehr besondere Geschichte, dass er, der ja jahrzehntelang, muss man ja fast sagen, im Schatten von Totti stand. Sein Spitzname war immer Kapitán Futuro, also der zukünftige Kapitän.
Ah, ist so wie Prinz Charles, der zukünftige.
Ja, ist überhaupt nicht negativ gemeint oder so, sondern logischerweise war er ja logischerweise auch der, der so ein bisschen unter Tottis Fittichen, halt dieses römische halt auch immer verkörpert hat. Und dass der jetzt in der ersten Saison nach dem Abgang von Totti, wo er jetzt wirklich halt auch der Kapitän ist, ja, der vielleicht auch die Jahre davor, wenn man schon ein bisschen im Hintergrund im Mittelfeld war, dass der sozusagen auch mit der Art und Weise, wie er das Spiel bestritten hat, da herausragt, finde ich, ja, ist eine sehr schöne Geschichte und auch repräsentativ. Und ich glaube, wenn man im Duden ein Foto unter Mentalität reinmachen wollen würde, dann wäre man mit einem Foto von Daniele de Rossi nicht ganz verkehrt. Also man hat gesehen, wie er die Mannschaft mitreißt. Man hat das auch in den Wochen davor schon gesehen. Gegen Donetsk, da gab es auch ein paar Bilder, das sind so kleine Zeichen, finde ich. Da hat ja auch Dzeko dann relativ spät das 1-0 gemacht, durch das die Roma weitergekommen ist. Da laufen neun Mann auf Dzeko halt zu vorne. Was macht der Rossi? Der Rossi dreht am Mittelkreis ab und läuft zu Alisson zurück zum Torhüter und springt den an, weil der logischerweise auch einer der ganz großen Faktoren in dieser Mannschaft ist. Das sind halt so kleine Zeichen, wo du halt merkst, der Mann lebt logisch die Roma, wie es vielleicht davor Totti gemacht hat, wie es als Niemand und der schafft es aber halt auch, jetzt trotz seiner 34 Jahren in solchen Spielen halt immer noch eine Performance hinzulegen, mit der er die Mannschaft mitreißt und mit der es seiner Mannschaft halt auch ausgeglichenheit und auf dem Platz gibt. Zweikampfverhalten, glaube ich, kennt man, aber halt auch diese öffnenden Pässe, die er dann gespielt hat. Er hat Schäkow auf die Reise geschickt zum 1-0. Er hat den Jäster aus dem Spiel genommen. Also das sind dann viele so Sachen, wo du halt merkst, dass das halt einfach ein kompletter Mittelfeldspieler ist und der es schafft jetzt auch immer noch auf so einem Niveau, das sozusagen einen ganz wichtigen Spiel zu liefern.
Es ist wirklich so grotesk, dass ausgerechnet in diesem Jahr die Italien nicht bei der Weltmeisterschaft sind. Also ich glaube, diesen Gedanken hatten viele Leute jetzt in den letzten Tagen. Wahnsinn. Aber unglaubliche Nacht von Rom. Ich glaube, über die Reaktion, wie es gerade so in Italien abgeht, reden wir mal, wenn wir über die anderen beiden Spiele noch gesprochen haben, weil irgendwie kam ja ganz viel zusammen. Denn schon am Tag danach trifft Real Madrid auf Juventus Turin. Real Madrid mit 13-0 in Turin gewonnen, unter anderem mit dem schönsten Fallrückzieher, vielleicht seit Klaus Fischer gegen Frankreich. Die Älteren werden sich noch erinnern. Und dann führt man 3-0 bis zur Nachspielzeit, kassiert dann einen Strafstoß, Buffon mit rot runter, wahrscheinlich eventuell die letzte Aktion von ihm in der Champions League. Können wir gleich noch drüber reden. Und dann scheidet man aus durch ein Treffer in der 96. Minute durch Cristiano Ronaldo. Lass mal, bevor wir über die ganze Schlussphase sprechen, über das sprechen, was da davor passiert ist. Ich habe das Spiel nicht über 90 Minuten sehen können. Ich habe mich zu spät entschieden, das Spiel über 90 Minuten zu sehen. Das war ein deutlicher Fehler, da auf Bayern gegen Sevilla zu gehen. Und da hatte ich den Eindruck, dass Real hatte die Spielkontrolle, in dem Sinne, dass sie den Ball haben durften, aber nur in den Bereichen, wo es nicht wehtat. Und da hat Juve gesagt, alles cool. Wenn ihr den Ball verliert, müsst ihr wissen, wir sind ganz, ganz schnell durch und dann kommt eine Flanke. Und da haben sie zwei super Treffer gemacht. Aber Juve hat das unglaublich clever gespielt, fand ich. Und auch hier wieder ein sehr, sehr frühes Tor. Zweite Minute, Manczukic. Und man hätte eigentlich denken können, mein erster Gedanke war, oh, das war zu früh. Denn jetzt wacht Real auf. Jetzt wissen sie, die müssen auf jeden Fall was bringen. Jetzt machen sie irgendwie innerhalb der ersten Halbzeit ein Tor. Also es war einer der Gründe, warum ich nicht umgeschaltet habe. Ja, dann kam der 37. das 2 zu 0. Man dachte sich so, ist ja interessant. Wie hat Juve das geschafft?
Ich glaube, da müssen wir auch mit dem Trainer anfangen. Mit Massimiliano Allegri. Auch das ist so eine Geschichte. Klar, du verlierst daheim 0-3 gegen Real. Puh, ich glaube, die öffentliche Wahrnehmung nach war klar.
Hätte auch noch deutlicher sein können. Also es war wirklich…
Ja, logisch. In den letzten Minuten ging es, wobei man auch da sagen muss, eine Stunde lang war Juve im Hinspiel richtig gut. Also die kassieren halt da das frühe Gegendorf, machen es dann eigentlich nicht schlecht. Und dann kommt diese eine Szene, die auch nur dadurch entsteht, dass dieses kurze Missverständnis zwischen Buffon und Queline ist. Klar, dann macht der Portugiese das Tor, über das in vielen Jahren noch gesprochen wird. Dann gibt es die gelbe-rote Karte, alles klar. Und dann, logisch, hätten sie auch noch eins, zwei kriegen können. Absolut. Der Punkt ist, sie hätten davor aber auch eins machen können. Und sie haben in der Nachspielzeit gab es auch eine kritische Situation mit Quadrado im Strafraum. Und das allein, ich habe Allegri in den ersten Minuten gesehen. Klar, auch ihr wieder das frühe Tor. Ohne sowas kommt vielleicht sowas auch gar nicht erst auf den Weg. Aber man hat Allegri in dem Moment schon angesehen. Der war nicht da, um einfach noch mit einem netten Spiel nach Hause zu fahren. Sondern der war da, weil der das innen eingeflößt hat. Jungs, schauen wir mal, was passiert. Und das, finde ich, hat sich durchgezogen. Es ist, wie du sagst, gerade nach dem 0-1 war eine Drangphase von Real. Absolut. Wo man wieder das Real gesehen hat, das man kennt. Wo sie auch ein Tor machen können, keine Frage. Aber dass Juve eine Mannschaft ist, die auch in der Abwehr, sag ich mal, positiv besetzt leiden kann und auch mal ein paar Minuten Druckphase überstehen kann, weiß man. Und dann fand ich, war das halt taktisch schon ein großes Kino, was er da auch wieder gebracht hat. Denn man kann logisch sagen, ja klar weiß jeder davor, dass Mancukic zwei Köpfe größer ist als Kavahal da auf der linken Seite. Das ist richtig. Aber du musst die Spieler dann halt auch dazu bringen, dass sie da so in Szene gesetzt werden und dass er in den Momenten reinkommt. Und das haben sie großartig gemacht. Die hätten ja sogar auch früher schon das 2-0 machen können. Da gab es glaube ich zwei Higuain-Szenen und so. Und dann hat man halt auch da wieder gemerkt, finde ich. Und das ist, finde ich, schon noch mal fast beeindruckender als das von der Roma, weil das war halt A, wieder zu Hause und B, in einem Stadion, in einem gewissen Stadion, Bernabeu, das ist jetzt nicht als das einfachste, leichteste. Das ist auch vielleicht mit der Historie A von Real und auch mit der Historie von Real in den letzten drei Jahren. Und ich finde, man hat Real wirklich angemerkt, spätestens nach dem 2.0, dass die sehr viel nachgedacht haben und dass die sehr angespannt waren. Man hatte nur Ronaldo, hat ungefähr, ich glaube, jeden Kontakt mit dem Schiri gesucht, um ihm seine Unzufriedenheit mitzuteilen. Ronaldo hat, glaube ich, in der 50. Minute, an der zweiten Hälfte, das Publikum bei jedem Einwurf heiß gemacht und so. Also man hat schon gemerkt, wowowow, die wissen, das schaut nicht gut aus oder kann was auf den Weg kommen. Und dass das Juwe geschafft hat, eben unabhängig von der letzten Szene, über die wir wahrscheinlich noch sprechen werden, ist, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Mannschaften in Madrid, die in Madrid ein 3-0 gebraucht haben, also nicht am Ende raus vielleicht noch zwei Kontertore geschossen haben, weil Real aufgemacht hat oder so, in einem Co-Spiel, ob es das schon mal gab, dass eine Mannschaft bis zur 97. und da 3-0 geführt hat. Viele, glaube ich, waren es nicht, dürften es nicht gewesen sein. Und deswegen ist es logisch aus Juwe-Sicht sehr schade. Es passt logisch auch ein bisschen ins Juwe-Bild mit der Champions League. Juwe und die Champions League in solchen engen Momenten ist nicht die glücklichste Geschichte. Aber ich würde schon – das haben jetzt vielleicht einige vergessen, wenn man sich die Jahre anschaut, wenn man hernimmt ab 2015, also inklusive dieser Saison die letzten vier Spielzeiten – dann war Juwe zweimal im Finale, hat zweimal dabei Real und Barca in den Co-Dualen rausgenommen, ist jetzt so gegen Real ausgeschieden und das ist das andere Mal gegen Bayern ausgeschieden, weil EWRA damals, glaube ich, in der 90. Tempale nicht vor dem 16. geklärt hat, wo die Bayern das 2-2 machen und dann geht es in die Verlängerung. Also Juwe, würde ich sagen, ist eine der prägende Mannschaften der letzten Champions-League-Jahre und das hat logischerweise viel mit Alegre zu tun und auch viel mit diesem Kern um Buffon, um Chiellini, die das auf den Weg gebracht haben. Umso betreuerlogischer, dass es dann so enden muss, gerade bei Buffon logischerweise.
Endet das denn? Ist das sicher?
Er hat ein Interview danach…
Für mich ist er wie Horst Seehofer. Ich glaube erst, dass er weg ist, wenn er wirklich weg ist.
Das ist sicher nicht die falsche Einstellung. Er hat aber ein Interview noch im Bernabé unten gegeben, wo es ihm gemeint haben, wo es ihm gefragt haben, ist es wegen solcher Spiele so was Besonderes, Juve-Kapitän zu sein? Der sagt, genau deswegen, und genau deswegen wird es mir, das wird mir am meisten fehlen, hat er gemeint, nämlich, dass ich mit diesen Jungs nicht mehr aufs Feld gehen kann. Also ich glaube, nach der Saison ist Schluss.
Okay, und wie bewerten wir das dann sowohl die Szene zum Strafstoß, als auch das Verhalten von Buffon danach? Da habe ich auch viele unterschiedliche Dinge drüber gelesen.
Also ich würde mal sagen, den Elfmeter kann man geben. Da ist ein Kontakt da und logisch sehr unglücklich.
Nein, auf Großhöhe ist halt immer schwierig.
Absolut, deswegen kann man ihn geben. Bei Buffon kam, glaube ich, in dem Moment einfach, ist halt dieses ganze Ding zusammengebrochen. Er hat ja auch danach sehr deutliche Worte gewählt. Also anstelle eines Herzens einen Mülleimer in der Brust. Und war ja wirklich, was man von ihm auch eigentlich nicht so kennt, wirklich sehr böse noch, sage ich mal, auf dem Schiri. Ihm ging es halt einfach darum. Und das hat er schon relativ gut in den längeren Gesprächen illustriert. Er hat gemeint, er sagt, wenn so eine Situation entsteht, dass in so einem großen Spiel so eine spezielle Situation entsteht, dass eine Mannschaft so etwas auf den Weg bringt, mit dem kein Einziger gerechnet hat, dann hat er gemeint, dann erwartet er sich in so einer Situation dieses oft zitierte Fingerspitzengefühl. Und das, glaube ich, hat ihn dann logischerweise, ihm war dann in dem Moment sicher auch unterbewusst klar, dass das jetzt seine womöglich letzte Szene in der Champions League eben ist.
Seien Sie dann Moment?
Ja, kann man vielleicht so sagen. Und er war auch, das macht sie doppelt bitter, ich fand, das war eines der besten Buffonspiele der letzten Monate. Also ich hatte wirklich auch, da waren ein paar unangenehme Bälle dabei, da hat er keinen einzigen prallen lassen, alle festgehalten. Ich hatte wirklich irgendwann das Gefühl, er kriegt kein Tor und er hat ja auch kein Tor gekriegt. Also das Tor hat er dann fest nicht bekommen. Nein, wie gesagt, da glaube ich ist halt alles zusammengebrochen. Es ging ihm einfach darum, da ist er logisch übers Ziel hinausgeschossen, es ging ihm einfach darum, diesen Moment sozusagen, er hätte sich erwartet, dass ein Schiedsrichter in so einem besonderen Moment, wenn es ein ganz klarer Elfmetter ist, klar, geben, pfeifen, keine Frage, er fand ihn nicht so klar, dass er meinte, den muss man geben. Und dann fand er, ist das halt einfach in so einem speziellen Moment mit der Vorgeschichte, mit Hin- und Rückspielen, mit Werner Bo 3-0 aufholen, ist das einfach über ihn hier reingebrochen.
Also relativ untypisch für Gigi Buffon, wobei er auch, ich finde er und Cristiano Ronaldo, das sind so zwei Beispiele für Sportler, wo es anscheinend nur zwei verschiedene Sichtweisen drauf geben kann. Entweder man vergöttert sie, oder man ist derjenige, der den Finger hebt und sagt, aus Grund XY mag ich denjenigen überhaupt nicht. Und das ist mir bei der Berichterstattung und den Reaktionen vieler Fans auf Buffon auch wieder aufgefallen. Es gibt diejenigen, die sagen, ein Gentleman auf dem Platz, absolut Fair Play immer. Und es gibt diejenigen, die auch anhand einiger Beispiele, die man auch echt akzeptieren kann, sagen, naja, also so viel Fair Play ist da nicht immer. Und Juve ist ja auch nicht ganz umstritten, auch was die Sportlichkeit angeht. Ich finde das interessant, dass es solche Figuren immer gibt, aber irgendwie ja auch sehr wichtig für den Fußball. Also man kann da auch sehr gut drüber diskutieren.
Absolut. Was mir aufgefallen ist, es hat dann ja, ich glaube, es hat die Runde gemacht, dass er angeblich den Schiedsrichter zur Hölle geschickt habe. Ich habe logischerweise, ich habe nur die Bilder gesehen, ja, auf dem Platz. Und man, wenn man des italienischen Mächtiges, man konnte dann seine Lippen relativ gut lesen. Und das einzige, das ich gelesen habe, war, dass er dem Schiedsrichter nahegelegt hatte, er solle sich doch bitte mal auf die Toilette begeben. Und also so viel dazu, ich weiß jetzt nicht…
Gescheißen oder was?
Ja, genau, in die Richtung. Was jetzt logischerweise auch nicht sehr elegant und nicht, ja, wie soll man sagen, sehr vorbildhaft ist. Aber ich glaube, da entsteht dann halt oft auch so ein Social Media, das ist so eine künstliche Diskussion, die dann vielleicht auch manchmal überhöht wird. Und das wird dann vielleicht der ganzen Sache nicht gerecht. Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, also dass er rot bekommt, vollkommen legitim, dass das 3-Fmeter-Gepfiffen wird, auch, wie gesagt, kann man geben. Ja, es war halt so ein Moment, in dem ist einfach alles reingebrochen. Und auch, glaube ich, aufgrund dieser emotionalen Geschichte dieses Spiels, dieses Hallo, wir sind in der Mannschaft und wir führen hier 3-0 in Bernabeu, weil wir das 3-0 brauchen. Und ja, das war dann halt einfach, glaube ich. Da kamen dann so viele emotionale Faktoren zusammen, dass dann sowas entsteht.
Auch das war einfach eine besondere Nacht. Und dann macht ja auch Christiane Roneido mit 3, 4, 5 Minuten Bedenkzeit.
7, glaube ich, waren es dann.
Macht ihr das Ding halt einfach auch in den Winkel.
Relativ präzise.
Das kann man dann auch machen. Feiert dann sehr überschwänglich, gab es auch eine Kritik für. Aber so ist es halt. Also es werden auch, glaube ich, nie alle Leute mit einem zufrieden sein. Und man hatte so ein bisschen den Eindruck, es wäre so schön gewesen, diese Story ein zweites Mal zu erleben. Roma nimmt Barca raus, Juve nimmt Real Madrid raus. Egal, ob man jetzt Fan des spanischen Fußballs ist oder nicht. Es wäre eine schöne Geschichte gewesen. Und wenn den Leuten schöne Geschichten genommen werden, dann reagieren sie auch manchmal über.
Sehr schön gesagt, ja.
Und das war dann das Ausscheiden von Juventus-Türin gegen Real Madrid. Und dann hatten wir noch ein interessantes Spiel, nämlich in der Europa League. Da hat Lazio Rom gegen Salzburg gespielt, nachdem man im Hinspiel 4 zu 2 gewonnen hat. Und man hat es geschafft, durch Tore in der 72. 74. und 76. Minute 1 zu 4 zu unterliegen und damit auszuscheiden in der Europa League. Wie bewertest du das?
Ja, wild auch logischerweise. Und da muss man aber sagen, ich habe die Reaktionen von Lazio, sowohl von Insagi, vom Trainer als auch von Parolo, von Spielern. Und die haben das sehr nüchtern, sehr fair auch eingeschätzt. Sie haben gemeint, ja, brauchen wir nicht darüber reden. Also Insagi hat gemeint, das wird uns eine Lektion sein. Die wird uns hoffentlich noch sehr oft lehrreich sein. Parolo hat gemeint, wir haben uns wie Hühner angestellt oder halt sehr, übersetzt gesagt, sehr dumm angestellt, keine Frage. Gemeint, da hat halt einfach auch noch ein bisschen diese internationale Reife gefehlt. Und ja, ist schade für Lazio, weil Lazio, wenn man sich auch die Tabelle in der Liga anschaut, eine sehr, sehr gute Saison spielt, mitten im Kampf um die Champions League Plätze, sehr spektakulär spielt, haben es mir heute aufgefallen, haben sogar mittlerweile den besten Angriff der Liga, sind nur noch ein einziges Tor vom Torekord entfernt, von 110 Saisontoren in einer Saison. Das war mal unter Ericsson und das war ja noch Lazio damals. Da sind ja noch ein paar andere Spieler rumgelaufen, die Crestboss und so ein Ding dieser Welt. Also, die sind wirklich eine Offensivmaschine und umso erstaunlicher ist es logischerweise, die machen das. Die Pude durch Immobile führen 1-0 in der 5. und 5. Sitzung und dann denkst du dir, ja gut, das war's halt. Aber das haben die sich halt wahrscheinlich auch gedacht. Und dann sind wir halt wieder und das finde ich ist halt auch das Schöne an diesen letzten Europapokaltagen, wenn du halt irgendwie mit dem Kopf nicht voll da bist oder wenn du dem anderen vielleicht irgendwie kurz dran schnuppern lässt und dem irgendwie noch mal ein bisschen Aufwend gibst, dann klappt das anscheinend international in diesen Hin und Drück Spielen jetzt immer wieder und immer öfter. Das finde ich ja ein sehr schönes Zeichen, dass man einfach bis zum Ende oder vom Anfang an, im Idealfall auch bei, wenn man auf die Spanier schaut, dann einfach da sein muss und diese Mentalitätsgeschichte halt auch durchziehen muss. Deswegen, wie gesagt, für Lazio logisch wäre das jetzt eine Riesenchance gewesen, ins Halbfinale zu kommen, in International, La Valle dafür aufsehen zu sorgen. Aber ich glaube, das war auch in Sarge dann am Ende gemeint, wir haben am Sonntag schon wieder ein wichtiges Spiel. Dieses wichtige Spiel heißt Rom und heißt Derby, wo wir jetzt auch schon seit zwei Wochen alle sehr heiß sind und seit dieser Woche, glaube ich, noch ein bisschen heißer. Und da geht es ja im direkten Duell mehr oder weniger auch um die Champions League-Quali. Deswegen hat die Lazio auch noch einiges vor und ist jetzt dieses Ausscheiden sehr pitter, aber glaube ich, wird jetzt nicht die starke Saison, die sie definitiv zeigen, jetzt komplett über einen Haufen werfen.
Ja, auch sehr interessant, dass wir hier mit Juve, Roma und Lazio bei drei Vereinen jeweils die wesentlichen Stürmer alle schon mal in der Bundesliga gesehen haben. Tseko Manczukic und Ciro Immobile, letzterer, den hat man am seltensten gesehen und der war auch am schnellsten wieder weg. Aber finde ich sehr interessant, vor allem wenn man sich auch jetzt gerade mal so die Bundesliga anguckt und sich denkt, ach ja, so ein guter Mittelstürmer der Stunde, manchen Mannschaften ganz gut zu Gesicht. Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass es ein Fehler war, die Leute gehen zu lassen. Ich finde es einfach nur interessant, dass ausgerechnet, dass angeblich zur Defensive Italien solche Stürmerpersönlichkeiten hat. Und da haben wir über Napoli noch gar nicht gesprochen.
Ich würde gerade sagen, und Manzukic ist ja noch der am wenigsten Stürmer von denen genannte, weil er hat ja in den letzten Jahren bei Juve auch eine Metamorphose hingelegt, dass er eigentlich meistens über links kommt und über außen. Da hat sein taktisches Portfolio schon noch um einige Elemente bereichert. Absolut, und gerade JK um vielleicht nochmal doch kurz auf JK zurückzukommen, denn es sind nicht nur diese Saison, auch die letzte schon, ist schon sehr beeindruckend. Ich kann mich noch erinnern, die Roma hat ihn damals, und das muss man sich mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, die haben ihn ja aus Manchester von City geholt und haben damals – Achtung, festhalten – 15 Millionen Euro Ablöse gezahlt. Also das war der feste Bestandteil. Es kommen noch ein bisschen Variablen oben drauf, aber das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Klammerauf muss man auch dazu sagen, der hatte logisch da oben ein Gehalt, das sich nicht viele Mannschaften leisten können. Bei diesem Gehalt wird bei der Roma auch nicht viel weiter runtergegangen werden, weil ich weiß, es kommen ja noch zu Diskussionen, warum holen die nicht andere so einen Schäko. Da geht es eben dann auch um gewisse finanzielle Aspekte, die dann doch die Roma für so einen einzelnen Spieler leisten kann. Aber ich weiß nicht in den letzten Jahren, ob es viele Mittelstürmer gibt, die so eine körperliche Präsenz, also erstens mal die knipsen, weil seine Torquote spricht ja für ihn, aber die dann halt auch dieses körperliche Element reinbringen, die eine Mannschaft alleine einfach aufrücken lassen können, indem der vorne, dem kannst du ja teilweise, dem spielst du einen 30-Meter-Ball. Den fischt er sich aus der Luft, den macht er fest und dann rückt die Mannschaft nach. Also da gibt es nicht so viele. Da fallen mir vielleicht noch die Herrn Lewandowski und früher mal ein gewisser Herr Ibrahimovic ein. Aber so viele finde ich in dieser Kategorie aus Größe, Technik gibt es da nicht. Und deswegen, dass der jetzt in dieser Saison, wo er auch im Winter ja knapp davor war, verkauft zu werden, weil es ja auch das mit Celcius und sehr weit war, der aber selbst gesagt hat, er will in Rom bleiben, weil er sich da anscheinend so wohlfühlt, ist das schon eine sehr schöne Geschichte quasi, dass solche Stürmer dann halt auch logisch tragende Rolle spielen, um solche magische Nächte dann halt auch möglich zu machen.
Und wie ist jetzt gerade die Stimmung unter Sportjournalisten und Fans in Italien? Das waren ja drei völlig wilde Tage. Man konnte es sehen, auf der Pressetribüne der Roma nicht mehr klar zu unterscheiden vom Fanblock. Ich habe da leicht ironisch drüber getwittert. Die Ironie wurde nicht so wirklich erkannt. Es hat eine erbittete Diskussion ausgelöst. War mir wiederum eine Leere. Das nächste Mal kommt ein Smiley mit rein. Ich habe das gar nicht so wild gesehen, wie viele gedacht haben. Aber logischerweise dann auch jetzt rund um dieses Madrid-Spiel. Viele Diskussionen über den Schiedsrichter, rund um Buffon. Und jetzt dann als Zuccalie oben drauf, jetzt noch dieses Lazio-Spiel. Wie ist denn so die Gemengelage unter den Journalisten und im Fußballland Italien? Ein bisschen habe ich den Eindruck, gerade weil dieses WM aus wie so eine nässende Wunde ist, die ersten mit wahrscheinlich Schlusspfiff des Finales so langsam anfangen wird zu verheilen. Also das WM-Finales war das jetzt wie so ein kühlendes Pet, wo man gesehen hat, wir sind halt doch noch jemand im Fußball.
Also die Stimmung nach Rom war wirklich sehr beeindruckend für italienische Verhältnisse, denn in Italien muss man wissen, dass man vielleicht ja oft aus Deutschland kennt oder hört, von wegen, ja, wenn die Bayern international spielen, dann steht eigentlich fast das ganze Land auch hinter Bayern, weil die der Leuchtturm sind. Den Punkt kann man in Italien mal geflissentlich vergessen. Ja, absolut. In Italien, wenn Milan spielt, dann gibt es für Interfans nichts Schöneres, als wenn Milan irgendwie aufs Maul kriegt. Also jetzt mit Darmophos gesprochen oder halt fußballisch überholt gesprochen. Diese Rivalität, die das Fußballland ausmacht, wird gerade auch in diesen Europapokal-Abenden zelebriert. Also in Italien, wenn Juwe verliert, dann sind die Juwe-Fans traurig klarerweise und fast alle anderen Fans in Italien sind glücklich oder freuen sich, weil Juwe das Establishment, das große, gegen das Beheim, oft diese Vorteile hatte oder denen diese Vorteile unterstellt werden. Deswegen, die Vorgeschichte muss man wissen. Und das war jetzt nach Rom anders. Auch nach der Art und Weise, wie die Roma das einfach gegen Barca hinbekommen hat, war über die Fanlager übergreifend. Auch die Vereine haben die Vereine getwittert, z.B. alle haben der Roma gratuliert, Milan inter Juve. Das hat man so nicht gekannt. Da war wirklich so ein einender Moment, wo alle gesagt haben, hey, Chapeau, was die Francesco, über den wir jetzt auch noch gar nicht geredet haben, mit der Mannschaft gemacht hat oder die alle zusammen das gewuppt haben und einfach ein sehr wunderschönes Bild des italienischen Fußballs gezeichnet haben. Das war die Situation nach Rom, nach dem Realspiel, nach dem Juwespiel und das ist jetzt eigentlich auch die große Diskussion, die es seitdem gibt. Es wurden einfach sehr viele Rufe laut, auch nach dem Video-Scheats-Richter in Europa.
Den man ja aus der Serie A kennt.
Genau, das ist ja der Hintergrund eben. Aus Serie A kennt man es, da gibt es zwar auch über die ganze Saison gesehen sehr viele Diskussionen. Da gab es auch schon Situationen, wo es logischerweise noch nicht so rund lief, wie es laufen hat sollen. Aber faktisch ist, dass dann doch so da war, an dieser Elfmeterszene, dass die halt gemeint haben. Das hat Allegri gleich gesagt, das hat auch Anjeli, der Präsident, gesagt und die ganze Zeit titelt auch heute damit. Also, für so wichtige Momente, für so wichtige Spiele, da Italien schon auch derjenige ist, der da auf den Gasknopf drücken würde und sagt, komm, lasst uns das bitte auch in den wichtigsten Spielen einführen, weil es dann vielleicht auch zu gewissen Szenen nicht mehr kommen würde. Dass der Videoschiedsrichter den Elfmeter dann vielleicht auch gegeben hätte, alles möglich geschenkt, aber dieses Thema ist jetzt sehr präsent seit der Nacht von Madrid, absolut.
Und jetzt schauen wir mal auf die Liga. Das letzte Mal, als wir gesprochen haben, Roch Napoli, noch so ein bisschen am Titel, zwei Punkte waren es da auf Juve, jetzt sind es derer schon vier. Geht Neapel so ein bisschen der Saft im Tank aus, woran liegt das? Ich kann mich an ein Spiel erinnern, ich glaube gegen Sassuolo, bin mir gerade nicht ganz sicher, 1 zu 1, das habe ich auch gesehen. Viele, viele Chancen und der Ball wollte einfach nicht rein. So der Klassiker, wo man in Deutschland sagen würde, ja, die Bayern gewinnen so ein Spiel noch und eben XY hat es jetzt nicht gewonnen. Dieses Gefühl hatte ich bei diesem Spiel. Liegt es da dran bei Neapel oder kann man es noch an anderen Faktoren festmachen?
Es geht, glaube ich, schon in die Richtung. Also erstens muss man ja sagen, es sind vier Punkte, aber es gibt ja noch das direkte Duell. Also da ist schon noch, würde ich sagen, alles drinnen, weil man jetzt vielleicht auch bei Juve wirklich auch schauen muss, wobei Juve logisch an Souveränität und so in Italien nicht zu überbieten ist. Aber trotzdem, so eine Nacht kann vielleicht halt auch im Kopf zwei, drei Narben zurücklassen, die man jetzt dann halt auch quasi in der Liga wird sich zeigen, glaube ich. Zwar nicht groß, aber wird sich auch alles zeigen. Napoli hat, wie du es sagst, Napoli ist eigentlich nicht von seinem Spiel weggekommen. Also es war jetzt nicht so, dass Napoli in den letzten Wochen plötzlich abgefallen ist. Aber genau das – ich glaube, das letzte Mal haben wir es kurz angerissen – das, was sie davor geschafft haben in der Saison, auf beeindruckende Weise, nämlich genau gegen diese kleinen Mannschaften, gegen die sie einfach wahnsinnig viel Ballbesitz haben, durch ihr sehr ansehnliches Ballstaffettenspiel. Da haben sie es geschafft, eben pissen März, diese Spiele dann doch zu gewinnen mit ihrer Klasse auch, mit ihrer taktischen Idee. Und da gab es jetzt zuletzt eben wieder ein, zwei Momente, wo sie wieder richtig sackt, der Ball läuft, sie spielen sich Chancen raus, wo dann halt einfach dieses letzte Quentin vielleicht dieser letzte Quentin Wille gefehlt hat vorm Tor. Und ich muss das auch nochmal aufmachen, logischerweise spielt auch immer eine Rolle, die sehen, wir sind dran, die waren ja sogar mal kurz vorne, aber irgendwie Juwe lässt sich durch nichts abschütteln, im Gegenteil, zieht dann auch wieder vorbei. Und das ist in den Köpfen von Napoli eindeutig drin, also dass sie das Gefühl haben, wir spielen schon wieder eine überragende Saison, 24-5-2, glaube ich, siehe unentschieden Niederlagen. Und trotzdem haben die immer das Gefühl, egal ob sie vorlegen, ob Juwe nachlegen muss, Juwe liefert. Und dieses psychische Element zu wissen, dass sie sich selbst keinen einzigen Fehltritt leisten dürfen, ist halt glaube ich auch nicht ganz von der Hand zu weisen und spielt eine große Rolle.
Absolut. In zehn Tagen, also am 22. April, kommt es zu einem Duell zwischen Juwe und Napoli, auch genau in dieser Konstellation. Das heißt, das Spiel wird in Turin stattfinden. Und schon an diesem Sonntag kommt es zum Römer Derby. Lazio gegen AS und mal kurz die Tabellensituation für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer aufgedröset. Lazio und die Roma haben 60 Punkte, liegen damit auf Platz 3 und 4 bei der Champions League Plätze. Und dahinter lauert Inter-Mailand mit 59 Punkten. Was ich natürlich sehr erhoffen wird, dass es da eine Punkteteilung gibt, dass man da vorbeigehen kann. AC, also Milan, liegt dann auf Platz 6, allerdings schon deutlich dahinter. Das heißt, wir haben nacheinander Turin, Neapel, dann die Römer-Vereine, dann die Mainländer-Vereine. Kann man sich eigentlich ganz gut imaginieren.
Es ist ein sehr spannender Dreikampf einfach um diese letzten zwei Plätze in der Champions League. Ja, wie gesagt, die Lazio war auch schon vor ein paar Wochen eigentlich ein paar Punkte hinten, hat dann aber sich, wie gesagt, wunderbar nochmal eben, ich glaube, 109 Tore sind es jetzt. Immobile, glaube ich, nur Messi und Salah haben in ganz Europa, also von den großen Ligern, mehr Tore und auch mehr Assist-Punkte. Also ich glaube, Immobile hat jetzt 38 oder 39 Scorer-Punkte allein in der Liga. Stimmt, das sind 26 plus 9, da kommen ja noch ein paar in Europa dazu. Also, ja, das wird ein sehr heißes Rennen. Und gerade jetzt das Derby am Sonntag in Rom, also ich glaube, das ist schon eine sehr spezielle Fußballwoche in Rom. Also das Derby in Rom ist immer, egal wie die Saison läuft, ist immer ein sehr emotionaler Moment. Also man merkt, ich habe Freunde in Rom, da kriegst du wirklich auch mit wie die eine Woche davor. Da ist nur noch das Thema. Und jetzt wäre die Konstellation ja allein schon spannend genug mit diesen drei, vier Punkte gleich Champions League. Jetzt kommt auch noch dieses Barcelona-Ding dazu, dieses Lazio-Ding. Also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass Lazio vielleicht ein kleines bisschen mehr Interesse hat zu zeigen. Okay, liebe Burschen, ihr habt gerade Barca rausgefiedelt. Die ganze Welt redet über euch. Dann zeigen wir euch mal, wie das in Rom ausschaut von der von der Gemengelage her. Also schon ein sehr spezielles Spiel. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie das dann auch emotional wird. Und ja, genau Inter hat auch kurzzeitig mal ein bisschen Punkte liegen lassen. Dann hat Herr Icardi wieder angefangen, das zu tun, was er am besten kann. Zu knipsen. Und ja, das wird ein sehr, sehr spannender, spannender Drei-Kampf auch in den letzten Spielen.
Und stand nicht Milan, als wir das letzte Mal gesprochen haben, noch deutlich schlechter da?
Nein. Milan war A-Sechster und war sogar noch punktemäßig ein bisschen näher dran. Ja, die hatten, da gab es jetzt das Derby gegen Inter, das nachgeholt wurde, wo sie eine Null gespielt hatten. Also wenn sie eins gewonnen hätten, eins mehr, die haben auch einmal noch bei einem 1-1 gegen Kleineren und Vareinen Punkte liegen gelassen. Also es stand jetzt sogar so ein bisschen emotional im Raum, dass sich da Milan vielleicht auch noch mal ranrobben könnte. Stimmt, genau so haben wir gerichtet. Genau, das, glaube ich, dürfte jetzt durch sein, mit 8 Punkten Rückstand bzw. 7 auf Inter. Weil wir kurz noch hinschauen, vielleicht wirklich eine schöne Geschichte, die aus einer sehr tragischen Geschichte entstanden ist, ist wirklich die Fiorentina, die jetzt auf Platz 7 ist, auch nur noch 2 Punkte hinter Milan. Und das Beeindruckendste ist, die haben jetzt jedes Spiel seit Davide Astori verstorben ist gewonnen. Die haben jetzt 5 Spiele in Serie gewonnen. Haben dabei ein einziges Gegentor bekommen. Also man hat fast ein bisschen das Gefühl, als würde da noch jemand von irgendwo anders her mitverteidigen oder so. Und ja, sie sagen es selbst, die haben einfach diese sehr spezielle Konstellation. Wir haben ja das letzte Mal darüber gesprochen. Diese sehr emotionale Verbindung zwischen der Stadt, dem Verein, diese ganze Gemengelage hat die Mannschaft jetzt irgendwie geschafft, daraus irgendwie, ja, weiß nicht, ob man auch sowas was Positives ziehen kann, ob man das sagen kann, aber aus diesen Umständen einfach, ja, so einen sportlichen Schwung mitzunehmen, sehr beeindruckend und logischerweise eine sehr schöne Geschichte, dass diese Erinnerung halt auch irgendwie jedes Wochenende, die ja sowieso da wäre, aber halt momentan auch noch sportlich sehr positiv besetzt ist, weil die das logischerweise auch jede Woche sagen, ja, sein Geist trägt uns mit und ja, eine sehr schöne sportliche Geschichte.
Aktuell liegen sie zwei Punkte hinter Milan und damit auf Platz 7. Ist es in Italien auch so, dass der 7. Platz bei einer entsprechenden Konstellation im Pokal für die Europa League reichen könnte?
Könnte reichen, genau. Es geht ja dann um Coppa Italia auch und ja, also da ist auf jeden Fall alles noch drin.
Und noch ganz kurz ein Blick unten auf den Abstiegskampf, denn das sieht sehr, sehr spannend aus. Da haben wir auf Platz 18, das ist der erste Absteiger, und Platz 17 zwei Vereine mit 27 Punkten, Ferrara und Crotone. Und darüber dann mit Caliari, Chievo, Verona und Sassuolo drei Teams mit 29 bzw. 30 Punkten. Das heißt, da ist es noch relativ eng beieinander, von Platz 14 bis Platz 19. Das sind fünf Punkte.
Ja, sehr eng. Also, Benevento ist weg. Die hatten so ein kleines Zwischenhochheben als Letzter mit 13 Punkten. Aber der Rest hat sich sehr viel getan. Auch Hellas Verona war eigentlich bis vor ein paar Wochen, dachte man, keine Chance. Die haben angefangen zu punkten. Spall macht es sehr gut als Neuling. Zum ersten Mal wieder da, hält sich gut. Das Negativbeispiel darin ist Caliari. Die kriegen seit Wochen nichts mehr auf die Reihe. Die waren eigentlich bis vor ein paar Wochen zumindest im gesicherten hinteren Mittelfeld. Da ist jetzt auch so eine Stimmung entstanden, dass es auch immer wieder in Italien passieren kann. Der Druck von außen wurde sehr groß. Da ist sehr viel Druck von den Fans, auch vom Umfeld. Die Mannschaft hat das in den letzten Wochen überhaupt nicht mehr gebacken bekommen. Plötzlich sind die da mittendrin. Mit dem haben die sicher auch nicht damit gerechnet. Genau, Cortone macht das. Ich glaube, bei den Mannschaften stehen die auf jeden Fall gut da, damit sie sagen können, wir sind noch im Rennen. Absolut, Cortone und Verona beide gewonnen am Spiel. Cortone ist interessant. Er ist ja Walter Zenga-Trainer, den vielleicht noch der eine oder andere aus der Vergangenheit kennt. Der war schon in Rumänien teilweise. Er ist kein schlechter Trainer. Er hat von seiner Art und Weise manchmal vielleicht nicht die großen Möglichkeiten bekommen. Aber der jetzt mit Cortone das sehr gut macht. Kjewo und Verona kennen das Spiel. Für sie ist das nichts Neues. Ich glaube, das sind die, die in der Konstellation die die größte Erfahrung haben, die mit ihren bescheidenen Mitteln das doch jedes Jahr meistens hinkriegen. Zasuolo ist der Ex-Verein von Eusebio Di Francesco, vom Roma-Trainer. Di Francesco hat ihn vor drei oder vier Jahren zum ersten Mal in die Serie A gebracht, ist mit denen aufgestiegen und ist mit denen sogar in den Europapokal gekommen. Sie haben Europa League gespielt. Was ganz witzig ist, haben damals mit alles, Zasuolo ist bekannt dafür, fast nur junge Italiener zu haben, haben einen sehr, sehr schönen Offensivfußball unter Di Francesco gespielt, sehr aufregend. Und die haben damals in der Europa League gegen Athletic Bilbao gespielt, 3-0 gewonnen, und der Trainer von Bilbao war ein gewisser Herr Valverde, der jetzt am Dienstag auch in Rom zu Gast war und von Di Francesco zum zweiten Mal mit dem 3-0 nach Hause geschickt wurde.
Ach, das sind so die kleinen Geschichten, die ich dann gar nicht auf dem Schirn habe, weil ich nicht so tief drin hänge. Ja, und mit Ball und Zasuolo haben wir auch zwei Teams, die da unten drin hängen, aber eigentlich alles dagegen tun. Also allein in den letzten sechs Partien ist Ball unbesiegt, vier Unentschieden, zwei Siege, Zasuolo, vier Unentschieden, ein Sieg und nur eine Niederlage. Könnte man jetzt auch parallel zur Bundesliga ziehen, da ist auch so manches Team jetzt hinten reingerutscht, einfach weil man ja nicht mehr gewonnen hat. Und die von hinten vor allem sich jetzt langsam randrobben. Also es wird ein super spannendes Saisonfinale, würde ich sagen.
Absolut, also da ist noch ein. Und wie gesagt, auch vorne dran, klar, vier Punkte. Das klingt jetzt erstmal, ja, es ist Juve, also klar, ich würde mich jetzt nicht wundern, wenn die das auch durchziehen. Aber wie gesagt, da ist das direkte Duell, auch wenn das in Turin ist. In Erpel ist alles in jedem Spiel zuzutrauen, gerade in den großen Spielen. Und von dem her glaube ich auch, dass das noch nicht komplett durch ist.
Ja, und es gibt ja vor allem jetzt noch einen Spieltag davor. Also vielleicht stolpert ja Juve doch nochmal. Die haben jetzt auch viel zu verarbeiten mit Madrid und so weiter. Ja, spannende Situation. Ich könnte mit dir noch ewig sprechen, aber wir machen ja einen Kurzpass. Vielleicht ist das der Fehler. Vielleicht müssen wir diese Sendung immer zum Tribüngespräch machen. Oder du kommst einfach wieder. Aber ich glaube, wir haben es ganz gut umrissen. Und es hat sich ja jetzt auch wunderbar getroffen mit der Champions League und Europa League Saison. Wir wissen jetzt, stand der Aufnahme auch noch nicht gegen wen in der Champions League, die das Halbfinale gespielt wird. Ist insofern aber nicht schlimm, liebe Hörer und Hörer. Selbst wenn bereits ein italienischer Verein vielleicht auf einen Deutschen trifft oder es eine andere interessante Konstellation gibt, so vorschauen kriegt ihr überall sonst. Hier im Rasenfunk wird immer nur zurückgeblickt. Da kann man nämlich schlauer tun.
Da macht man einen clevereren Eindruck. Mal schauen, vielleicht gibt es aber wirklich noch die Konstellation über die Roma zum Beispiel auch nochmal ganz besondere Geschichtchen oder Dinge auszupacken. Es gäbe einige, es ist wirklich eine schöne Geschichte, dass der Roma das gelingt. Wir haben jetzt ein, zwei Mal angerissen. Die Fußballstadt Rom ist wirklich ein sehr spezielles Pflaster. Da stecken so viele Emotionen drin, da steckt so viel Herzblut auch von den Leuten mit drin, dass es für die Mannschaft, für die Spieler eben nicht immer alle einfach macht. Im Gegenteil, da ist dann oft so viel Druck und so viel Aufmerksamkeit da, dass es einfach zu viel wird. Aber dementsprechend umso mehr, wenn die Roma es schafft, so große Momente zu erreichen, dann ist da irgendwie so viel fußballerische Liebe, die das Ganze umgibt. Und so viel hat man jetzt ja die Bilder auch gesehen. Wirklich finde ich eine sehr spezielle Fußballstadt in ganz Europa.
Mein Lieblingsvideo aus dieser magischen Nacht war der Vereinspräsident, der sich in den Brunnen geschmissen hat.
Der auch gleich gesagt hat, kein Problem, er zahlt sofort die Strafe. Und er hat sogar am Tag darauf an die Stadt Rom 230.000 Euro gespendet, um viele dieser Brunnen zu sanieren zu können. Also ja, hat die Brieftasche dann doch ein bisschen weiter geöffnet, sozusagen in der Euphorie.
Man möchte sich nicht ausmalen, was passieren würde, sollte die Roma ins Finale einziehen?
Schwer einzuschätzen.
Das Positivste daran wäre, neben vielen anderen positiven Dingen, dass wir auf jeden Fall noch mal darüber sprechen würden.
Absolut, sehr gerne.
Das war Christian Bernhardt, freier Autor unter anderem für die Süddeutsche Zeitung. Vielen, vielen Dank, Christian, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst.
Ja, vielen Dank dir, Max, und bis bald.
Und danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, fürs Zuhören. Hört das aktuelle Tribüngespräch. Das lohnt sich auch über das Tschutti-Häftli. Macht's gut, ciao.